Winston Marshall played lead guitar in
Banjo for the band Mumford and Sons
which became internationally famous and
successful for good reason they're great
then he made the mistake of mildly
praising a book about antifa writers
that he read written by Andy now
and his life just changed in an instant
he became a political figure he didn't
want to be and ultimately he was
attacked so harshly he had to leave the
band
so we thought it'd be interesting to
spend an hour with him and we just did
for a brand new episode of Tucker
Carlson today he's a pretty amazing
person actually we discovered here's
part of our conversation
[Music]
the music and the creative Industries
more broadly
was ever you know there was it was the
black squares on on social media and if
you remember there were a lot of actors
and actresses
uh fronting money to bail out the
various um uh rioters and and there was
a big social media campaign that raised
money here and they were bailing out the
those who were arrested in the 2020
um riots
and so that's the actually the
atmosphere and I guess that's perhaps
why what happened to me had to me is
because it was so contrary to the
prevailing
um
politics I guess of of the um creative
Industries so I had very few followers
by the way I think about 3 000 followers
on Twitter somehow this book and it does
it honestly feels like an act of God
which I know that sounds a bit
crazy but it it doesn't for the record
it doesn't sound crazy at all my life uh
sort of started to crumble initially I
was like so what it'll pass but right
that's when you get the sort of phone
calls from loved ones and friends and
and people you work with just panicking
and uh so
this dog pile actually became a almost
real life dog pile of of just everyone
in my life
um around me and um what was their
complaint
well I guess I
I well the people I were working with
they were getting attacked by these
antifa maybe not quite as much as me but
they were you know under they were
getting harassed by these people as well
and they're very effective online like
for example
there was a whole night where they were
changing my Wikipedia page from Winston
Marshall Marshall is a banjo player to
Winston Marshall is a fascist and it was
just oh I had another friend trying to
change it back and they've just all
night like at it and they just swarm you
like hornets and everything they do to
try and destroy you
if you wind up as a society that cannot
tolerate a man like Winston Marshall who
is rational
reasonable decent
that's a problem that's on you not on
Winston Marshall that whole
conversation's on Fox Nation right now
well worth it subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight